is it trash to keep your fast food warm
by cranking the defrost on high and
leaving it on the dash
[Applause]
that's like a Viking Range that is
[ __ ] air fryer this Volkswagen
I'll get those fries crispy in one
minute
[ __ ] hey when was the last time you
did that
it makes sense man I can't hate it he
goes in a drive-through just get some
cold don't worry I'll heat him up myself
I'm making the burger in the car
oh man what's your go-to fast food
though
this kid's all right
bless I take back everything I said you
could have said anything he would have
been on board
[Laughter]
if we're being honest right
the question
I mean this guy's name is Kyle AKA
Vinnie
it's a real Ethan move right there yeah
where are you at
yeah you're in the back for sure
I'm technically not even in the showroom
Kyle where do you live man you got a
house you had an apartment
nice you own it or you rent it very nice
you got a mortgage
oh [ __ ]
it's not an act
it's not an act
[Applause]
he's on a diet he was eating Tostitos
pizza rolls seven minutes ago leave
Melody hasn't eaten in 15 minutes
all right somebody get some fun dip
quick
I need three CC's a Twizzlers stat
all right so you're renting
okay very cool what kind of car do you
drive
is that at least 30 is that a mortgage
what do you got
the Elise around
you own it look at you you're still
making payments on it
what year is it
oh we might have a little couple of
bucks on them here well his question is
it garbage to clean your above ground
pool with the pasta strainer from the
kitchen
that's real Vinnie's [ __ ] if he asks me
Kyle would never go for that
why is there beetles in this fettuccine
oh tell me you have it tied to like a
[ __ ] broomstick or something
you're just walking around the pool with
the pasta strainer for some reason I
picked you in your work clothes doing
that he's got boots on
just sitting there in a nice suit
plop it up for Kyle one time guys what
I'm talking here
I
one last question do you then take the
post trainer back into the house and use
it in the kitchen
yeah they're not animals
chlorine kills everything
has a nice taste to it too clap it up
for Vinnie Kyle everybody
beautiful
all right where's Angela T
okay how are you Angela
good who are you here with
okay Angela have you had meatloaf in the
last 365 days
pretty good have you ever eaten a
hard-boiled egg in public
wow that is a tough one we got a system
answer the question young lady
and if it's yes do you have any on you
have you done that
about it
[Applause]
Angela's question did you arrive to your
prom or wedding on a tractor or other
piece of farm equipment
how many people did that for a round of
applause
well one excited guy
who for sure went to the prom alone
I was gonna say he went with Angela
I still love you baby
Angela did you do that
your Jesus Christ what did you roll up
on
all right [ __ ] relax Jacqueline
Kennedy
did you own it or did you have a
mortgage on it
and what did you go where did you go and
on what I drove a four tractor to sit
till at my high school in Jerome Idaho
you drove it
dude how do you get a DUI on a tractor
how old were you
were you is that legal to drive it 14
. what the [ __ ] what are we in the 1920s
yeah
I picture him on the highway go around
go around
I got my kids here [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you guys are nuts yeah you
guys are wild man clapping up Angela
back there everybody
and one time for John Deere over here
yeah laid that night baby
I mean all right where's Alex L
yeah
was that to us or did the [ __ ] edible
just kick in
hey [ __ ]
you're gonna have to drive the tractor
home
I'm not even going to ask what your
credit score is dude
I'm sorry dude but you emailed us
oh man
everybody be cool how about that
I got you covered don't worry
this is a hypothetical obviously
about people who do not exist ever
anywhere
don't be a [ __ ] narc
is it garbage to illegally sell your
dead dad's handgun to your step dad
Portland that's [ __ ] it you guys have
been family you guys are amazing thank
you so much we'll be out front taking
pictures we have shirts we want to meet
everybody have a good night thank you